-You have a set.
Obviously, you get
to design a set.
What did you want to represent
in the set
when you're sitting down
and just think about visuall
want you wanted to see?
-Oh, man, I had no idea.
To be honest, I feel like --
-I totally didn't either.
-I'm pretty good at
visualizing what a script
is gonna turn into.
-Yes.
-What lyrics will turn into.
The set was so out
of my comfort zone.
-I have no visual style.
-Oh, 100%.
-Yeah.
-My set designer was like,
"And then this contraption
will open."
I'm like, "I have no clue what
you're saying to me right now.
But I'm really happy with
how it turned out.
I think it's super cool.
It's modern. It's funky.
-There you go.
-Yeah.
-There's a little sneak peek
at the set.
And then that --
Tell us a little bit about that.
-So, on my desk I have
the two loves of my life.
So my dog, Scarborough.
And French fries.
-Okay, French fries
and Scarborough.
-Yes, correct.
-I think a lot of people lov
French fries and their dog
But they rarely have the photo
-Really? That's weird.
-Yeah, they never
have the frame.
-And this is based on a true
story because for about a year
I did have a framed picture of
like, a Big Mac combo
on my night table.
-Uh-huh.
-I thought it was, like,
aesthetically pleasing.
-Sure, they put a lot of wor
into making those Big Mac combos
look it.
-You're supposed to frame
pictures of things you love.
-Yeah.
-And so there you go.
-There you go.
-Yes.
-Scarborough is named
after your hometown?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Yes. Scarborough is named after
my home town in Toronto.
I mean, can we take a moment
The only reason
I want to be successful
is to give my dog a better life.
Like, I swear, I'm obsessed.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you feel as though
at this point
he doesn't have
a good enough life?
Has he complained at all?
Has he --
-You know, he could have
more costumes.
He could have a bigger yard.
He could have -- I just --
-I don't think many -- I think
this is a photo of a dog,
when he hears you want to ge
him more costumes.
I think that is what they do
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, he's so sweet.
-He is very sweet.
-He's so, so sweet.
-Who are your guests
this first week?
-So, this first week, our firs
show tonight, is Mindy Kaling.
-Very good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Rainn Wilson.
-Excellent.
-Yep. And then we've got
Kenan Thompson.
-Great.
-Yep.
-One of the all-time greats.
Got Chelsea Handler.
-Uh-huh.
-And we got Tracee Ellis Ross,
so it's a stacked week.
-That's a very good first week
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, looking back,
one of my favorite things
about that beginning
when you have a show --
So you've known --
So what have you known?
About six months that you've had
this coming, seven months?
-Probably a little longer.
-Yeah. So it's like
putting together a staff.
That's one of
the most exciting things.
You have all these slots
to fill.
Was it fun putting togethe
a writing staff?
-It was a double-edged sword
I mean, it's super cool
'cause I have more than
five people working on stuff
-Yeah.
-But it's also --
I have no idea what anyone does.
-Oh, yes.
You mean on your crew.
-Oh, 100%.
-Yeah.
-Every day someone comes up to
me and says, "Hi, I'm Chad
And I do something
with the script."
And I'm like, "What do you do?
I have no idea."
And I want to know so badl
because I know they're
all working so hard.
Another thing is because
I did everything by myself
for so long,
I have major trust issues.
-Oh, interesting.
-Like, 100%.
-That's what they say.
People who start on YouTube,
they don't trust anyone.
[ Laughter ]
-When the prop department tell
me they're gonna make a prop
I'm like, "But are you sure?
Like, "Are you gonna do that?"
I have a hard time believing
I don't have to do this.
So I'm a little bit -- a littl
annoying to my staff, probably
-And what about writers?
Like, what were you lookin
for in writers?
-Oh, yeah.
-'Cause that's another thing
You sort of wrote by yoursel
for all these years.
-Yeah, for eight years
I was writing my own stuff
And now I have a writers' room
which is fantastic.
I just need to humble-brag
for a second
because I think
it's very important.
I was very adamant on having
an inclusive writers' room
That is very important to me
so it has over 50% women.
-Congratulations. That's great
-And over 50% people of color.
-That's awesome.
-And I was very adamant of that.
Because, I mean,
obviously when I go out there,
you'll get my point of view.
-Sure.
-You know, a woman of color.
But I think it's so importan
to get the point of view
of my writers
because they're also so diverse.
I mean, that's what storytelling
and TV should be about.
It should be representativ
of the real world.
And I think that's so important.
So I wanted
an inclusive writers' room